why crypto so interesting to you given
kind of your background and like is this
just like the next evolution of that
internet one of the really interesting
things about the internet
is and it was really hard to define in
the early days
and i think it's actually pretty hard to
define today but um but we all know what
it is
and uh so one of the first
things that
was a challenge for us
as a venture fund in
2017 was to define the blockchain
and
just a little bit of background what you
asked for i i
started a
fund with two other people in
2017 called block change ventures
our mission is to invest early in
ideally what will become the biggest
outcomes of the blockchain
and the reason for that was really very
simple is every time there is a
generational technology shift new things
are made possible
and by that technology and so new
businesses new categories of business
are made possible for the first time and
that leads to a very fertile ground for
investing it means there's a lot of
startups it means that some of them will
go on to become very big outcomes
and we've seen that we saw that with the
computer and personal computer
uh technology wave we saw it with the
internet we saw it with the the adoption
of of mobile technology and the
blockchain
at the time seemed to be on the same
path
but it became very difficult to
uh to explain
why it was that the blockchain would be
so important and why it would create so
many outsized outcomes
and so we started by just trying to
define the internet we we saw some
similarities between the two i don't
think at the time we saw how similar
they were um
but
one of the things that we eventually got
to with the internet and i don't know if
you want to take a stab at defining the
internet but if you want to try you do
it uh you're the expert
i don't know that there is such a thing
but but but what we got to was really
simple uh was that the internet allowed
any two entities to exchange data in a
frictionless way
um information super highways yeah i
think is the terminology that's right so
so
but what that meant is that every
company
could could be described as a entity
exchanging data with another entity
so facebook could be described as uh
person uh entity one
sending some pictures and tax ie data to
entity to facebook and facebook then
sending that information to entity three
through n which are their friends
um and uber could be
described the same way entity one being
a person a passenger sending the gps
coordinates and their credit card data
to entity to uber who would then send it
to entity three the driver who would
pick them up
and having that as context made it much
easier to define the blockchain the
blockchain simply was changing one word
it's any entity exchanging value with
any other entity or any other entities
in a frictionless way
and so you could see how similar the two
were
uh it also allowed us to say okay what
worked for the blockchain for the
internet might work for the blockchain
as well
and so that became the formation of the
fund we used the historic filters and
you and i have spent some time talking
about this but we use
we tried to
we tried to
derive filters for what would have been
good filters for the internet
had we been investing early in the
internet so that we could use that as
the beginning of a framework for
investing in the blog what are like the
key pieces to that you know
they're they're not fundamentally
different than what you hear a lot of
investors talk about which is you know
um
why now could and the answer is always
because this company couldn't exist
before now so one of our filters is very
simply uh does this company
fundamentally depend on the blockchain
to exist
second one is always about team
in the case of the biggest outcomes one
of the things that was really different
about teams was that
they were they were there
way past the billion dollar
acquisition offer so teams tend to be
mission driven in the biggest outcomes
they tend to have the ability to recruit
extraordinary talent um
when they have a tailwind and some
growth
and they tend to still have one
participant still involved in running
the company 10 years in
when they're successful which means that
the founders are mission driven
um they have the ability to recruit and
uh they have some skill that is a
critical skill for some lever of value
creation
and and then the third main one
is around the market and they all
invented almost all of them invented new
categories of business so you don't
really know how big those markets are
but the markets
have to be at least potentially massive
they typically have monopoly or
oligopoly outcomes
and they're typically defensible through
network effects technology ip or
economies of scale
and one interesting thing when we went
to back test this was that most of them
had growth in margins over the first 10
years they become better businesses as
they get scaled that's right they they
capture more of the value they create
and and part of the reason for that is
if you capture too much value too
quickly
you open up the market to a lot of
competition
so if you look at amazon amazon may be
one of the first country companies in
history to consolidate a fragmented
market and i think one of the core
reasons for it was that they priced so
efficiently
and didn't make money in the early days
that no one wanted to be in that
business and so that allowed them to do
other things really well like service
and
delivery and convenience and
one-click shopping and
prime and
uh broad broad selection all of which
together made them the place you would
want to go first
and so we look for those kinds of
signals i think you added another one
on one of our conversations in a taxi a
few years ago
which
is often called traction
but most companies at the stage we
invest which is seed in series a don't
have traction so we look for leading
indicators of traction
which can often be small markets that
that our company is going after to get a
monopoly in and grow concentric
concentrically from there
or some really
10x improvement in product
or there's a variety of things but um
uh that we call it gravitational force
internally but that has become a fourth
filter ever since our taxi ride so thank
you hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time